>> KAY: So, I've talked a little bit before
about UIs. So, let's talk about--back a little
bit about the UI philosophy behind Chrome
and how it applies to extensions. So, as I
said, we're aiming for a very streamlined
and integrated user experience. The phrase
that Brian mentioned earlier is that we use
a lot inside the team is “Content, not Chrome,”
what that means is that we want people to
be able to focus on the content of the Web.
I mean, when people use a Web browser they
are interested in getting to the Web. They
don't care about the Web browser; really that's
just window dressing. And so, we'd like that
to disappear in to the background as much
as possible. So, these also apply--this philosophy
also applies the types of extensions that
we think about that we want to enable. Chrome
Extension should be more about helping you
discover content on the Web, or helping integrate
content in with the browser better and that
sort of thing. So, let's see, let's talk about
the some of the surfaces--we already talked
about the browser action a little bit, but
we only touched on one of the basic features,
which is just having an icon that you click
on and an action happens. We actually packed
a bunch of other little features here. If
you look at the Gmail Icon he’s got there,
you can see there's a little counter in the
corner. That's dynamic. It's overlaid on top
of the icons that we compute, so you can set
the color and put some text in there and rotate
through. So, in this case, it's really useful
for showing the number of unread messages.
Also, that image that the icon itself is totally
dynamic. So, you can, you know, animate through
a sequence of images if you'd like. And you
can even do that completely well and continuously
in some cases. In this case, actually, this
isn't like a pre-computed set of static images.
These are done generated on the fly dynamically
with the Canvas object from the background
page. So, we have a single bitmap and it's
rotating it through and setting it down. In
addition, browser actions can have a pop-up.
What a pop-up is it’s just an HTML content
that is sized dynamically or automatically
in this little bubble that’s attached in
the bottom. So, you could see when he clicks
on one of the stories and then it expands,
the bubble expands with it. We dynamically
sized it based on the content and in Real-Time.
Now, this is useful for more than just wheezy
animation. This is also really useful for
things like localization. You know, you might
have a word that in Chinese only two characters
and in German are fifty characters. I'm trying
to design a UI, a size, and all that layout
that works well in all those environments
is pretty hard. So, having to size it dynamically
for you is going to be a real time saver for
the developers. Another surface we have is
similar to a browser action. We call it a
“Page Action.” Page Actions appear instead
in the omnibox rather than in the toolbar
there. They have allotted the same features,
the dynamic icon, they have pop-ups. But the
thing that's different about them is that
they come and go based on the content of the
page. A browser action is meant to be a permanent
part of the browser UI, something that’s
always balanced, and something that will work
all the time. Whereas the Page Action says,
“Well, let me look at the content of the
page. And if it's appropriate, I'll show it
myself.” In this case, this Netvibes extension
detects RSS feeds on the page and only if
there's an RSS feed does it show the icon.
There's one more surface that is I sometimes
forget because it's so--it's sort of the ideal
minimalist surface, which is the page itself.
So, we have a functionality called Content
Scripts, which allows you to inject JavaScript
and CSS into the page itself and modify its
contents, maybe doing overlays or highlighting
stuff. And this is an incredibly powerful
feature and allows you to add UIs. So, let's
take a look at a simple example, something
you may have seen before. Here's Google Image
Search and this is just it with no extension
hooked in, but I'd like--I got an idea for
an extension that will take all of these images
and turn it into a nice pretty slide show
for me, so...
>> BOODMAN: That is a good idea.
>> KAY: Yeah, let's--well, good thing we have
thought about it before and I already have
it. So, let's just enable that one and reload
the page.
>> BOODMAN: Boom.
>> KAY: Okay. So, you see at the bottom here
a little sliding scroll view appears and there
are some nice little animations that you hover
over the individual images. And now, if you
click on the one that you want, you see it
as a nice fade in transition of the martial
arts kittens there. And as it goes pages between
them, it shows your nice animated slide show.
And the--can never go wrong with kittens.
So, okay. So, those are the UI surfaces that
we have exposed. We did spend a fair amount
of time as well on the management and administrative
UI of the extension system as well. We wanted
it to be as frictionless and out of the way
as it could be. So, install, uninstall, auto
update, we don't want to barrage you with
a bunch of dialogues, a bunch of questions
as you're going along. So, basically, it's
one or two clicks to install, the browser
doesn’t have to restart, you don't have
to, you know, God forbid, restart your computer,
you know, it just works for both uninstall
and install. And update is totally silent;
it uses the same technology that we use for
Chrome to keep itself up-to-date and can happen
live and in place while you're using the browser
even.
>> BOODMAN: So, you wanted to show a demo?
>> KAY: Yeah, yeah, why don't we install one
of those and check it out. So, here's one
of our samples that we had from way back when,
little Page--a Page Action that shows the
map. And it tells you in the dialogue what
this extension can do. And this one, it's
injecting Content Script in the page, so it
tells you it has access to the pages that
you're surfing to, so you install. And as
the Page Action, remember I said that the
Page Actions come and go. This one is based
on whether there's an address on the page
or not, this page doesn't have an address
on it. So, we actually at install time, always
show the icon briefly, so you know where the
UI is going to appear. So, it's not a mystery,
so you don’t--so you know what to expect,
and a little explanation about which extension
just got installed and how to get back and
how to uninstall if you'd like. So then it
disappears and we're done. Okay. So, as I
mentioned before, speed is really important
to the Chrome team. It's something that we
think about in almost everything we do. We've
got performance tests for most of the code
in the project. And the idea is that every
time that the developer checks in code, these
performance tests run and we can catch when
things slow down as a result and fix them
before they get released to the public. Extensions
are no different. Basically, we wrote some
tests that installed 50 little extensions
and SAJA that affected startup time and page
load time as we cycle through a whole bunch
of different pages from our sample set. And
when--so, we can catch these things when it
regresses, but it--in addition to catching
regressions, it also allows us to measure
experiments. Things what we think will improve
things. So, for awhile while we're developing,
Content Scripts did slow down page load time
a little bit, especially if you have a lot
of them. And one of our engineers, Anthony,
had a great idea for how to make that faster
and Aaron knocked out a quick test for it.
And this is actually a real graph from our
test when that happened. And you can see that
prior to this, the green line was much slower
than the blue one, which is with the--just
one Content Script installed and--but after
the fix, it went down to, basically, being
about the same. So, it's--this sort of Real-Time,
very fast turn around in performance testing
is really important to us. The other reason
why extensions perform really well in Chrome
it's because of our multiprocessor architecture.
So, if you're looking in Chrome’s Task Manager,
this shows you what all the processes are
that in use by Chrome. In addition to every
Tab being a process, every extension is also
a process. So, it's isolated from the browser
and isolated from each other. But this means
is that one poorly behaving extension doesn't
slow down the browser. The browser can run
independently. It doesn't slow down other
pages. It doesn't slow down other extensions.
So, the demo of this, we're going to install
or enable them, a badly behaving extension.
This extension is just going to spin the CPU
as fast as it can. And try to suck up all
the resources, this would normally, you know,
bring, you know, bring your system to a halt,
but let's see what it does to Chrome. Now,
he has enabled it. It's there. But you could
see that he can drag the tabs around. Everything
is still animating very smoothly. He can pull
out the tab. He can scroll around and read,
and do what he needs to do. And it doesn't
look like anything is going on. But let's
take a look and see what's happening. So,
if he brings out the task manager again, you
can see there's just one extension there that's
taking up 50% of the CPU. It's only 50% not
100 because I think his laptop is dual core.
So it's hitting one of his cores completely.
>> BOODMAN: I should use Web Workers then
I could use both.
>> KAY: Yeah, it's true. I should have thought
of that, man. So anyway, it sounds great.
The browser is still interactive but he is
on a laptop and it's probably getting warm
about now. You can hear his fan turning on.
So it'd be good if he could stop the offending
extension. So, one way you can do it is in
the task manager, you can just kill it. You
see something that's, you know, acting badly.
You can always just kill it in Chrome and
the browser will keep going, that's fine.
But in this case, I think it’s better for
us to just uninstall it and get rid of the
bad actor. So, let's just get rid of it, and
there it goes. It’s all done. Okay. So,
let's talk a little bit about security. Extensions
have access to what you're doing with the
browser. So, it's really important that we
build security in from the beginning. Really
think this through. We worked pretty closely
with the Security Researcher for Berkeley
named Adam Barth, who works with us on and
off in the Chrome project to help really build
something robust. And we're really proud that
he just published a paper recently about our
security model. And we think it's going to
be received pretty well. When we were thinking
about the model, we really thought about two
different use--two different threats that
we were trying to deal with. So, there's one
threat, which is if there are buggy extensions
out there. They are written by well-intentioned
people. They're not trying to do harm to you,
but they have bugs. And because of those bugs,
maybe they could be exploited by the attacker.
The other case is that you are an actively
hostile attacker, somebody who is really trying
to do harm and trick you into downloading
a bad code. Now, we spent more of our time
on the first case. The reason we did this
is because far and away, this is the most
common problem in security on the net right
now. Is that, you have people who write, you
know, they're writing code as a hobby, you
know, or it's--they're not security experts
to begin with, but they wrote something that
got really popular. And somebody comes along
and exploits the security holes that it has.
Security is really hard, so, you know, we
all write bugs. Software isn't perfect. Although,
I should say I'm sure nobody in this room
writes bugs but, you know, but it does happen.
So, how do we deal with those bugs? Well,
we got a few strategies for how to prevent
problems from happening. First, we use the
principle of least privileged. What this means
is that extensions only can do the minimum
that they need to do in order to do their
job. They declare upfront what permissions
they need, what host they need to talk to,
which browser APIs they want to use, and they
have to put that in their manifest. Uninstall
time as a user you can see what does this
extension do and know that it should never
be able to do more than that. That even if
it has a bug that an attacker won't be able
to trick it into doing something else. We
also used a console called privilege separation.
This is taking advantage of our multi-process
architecture and saying that the lower privileged
extension processes are separate from the
higher privileged browser process. So, that
means that those higher privileges can't leak
down into the extension, that even if, again,
if it has a hole, it can't get access to these
extra things. So, I talked a little bit before
about Content Scripts. Now, Content Scripts
are--as those of you who are familiar with
Greasemonkey and the related feature user
scripts are aware of are very powerful things.
And they have the potential of being kind
of dangerous as well. They can potentially
break the page that they're injecting into,
or they can actually accidentally grant the
page more privileges than the page originally
should have had. So, we protect against this
using a new technology what we call “isolated
worlds.” What an isolated world is, is a
way of separating the two things. We have
a separate context that the JavaScript from
the Content Script runs in and it keeps it
separate from other Content Scripts and from
the page itself. So, the variable names and
the functions, they don't interfere with each
other. And the page can't even find or get
access to the variables and the functions
inside the Content Script. Finally, when those
bugs do happen, it's important that the developer
be able to push out auto-updates as quickly
as they can. As I said before, extensions
use exactly the same auto-update mechanism
that Chrome uses itself. It's been hugely
successful in helping us mitigate problem,
you know, fix security problem very quickly
for Chrome. And when they've come up, we push
out results and get people updated within
hours or days. And the same thing is available
now to all extension developers and that's
built into the product. Also, the extensions
are all signed with public photography (ph).
So, that ensures that only the author of the
extension can push out updates to it. So,
let's talk a little bit about the hostile
case again. As I've said, we're more concerned
about the--about the buggy case but--because
in the end, extensions are going to be powerful
software, and you should only install them
from people you trust. Somebody could install
something, it does something. You couldn’t
install something that would do something
bad, but we do protect you from a certain
level of these problems. One way is using
the Sandbox. So, take our multi-process architecture.
So, each extension has its own process and
just like normal Chrome tabs, these processes
are Sandboxed. This means we're using the
operating--underlying operating system functionality
to limit its functionality. So, an extension
process can really only do what the browser
gave it permission to do to begin with. And
this means it can't talk to the network. It
can't talk to the file. It can't talk to the
registry. It can't do any of the things which
would let it be become really bad and persistent
in your machine after the fact. You can always
uninstall an extension when it’s misbehaving.
Finally, if a bad extension does make it down
for a while and somebody reports it to us,
we have the ability to blacklist that extension
and disable it after the fact. So, when that
happens, people who mistakenly installed this
bad extension will have it disabled and few
people in the future won't be able to install
it. So we have a pretty small set of designed
principles but we think about them in everything
we do in the Chrome Team. And when you applied
them to the extensions project, I think we
were able to build a pretty robust, easy to
use platform that--it's a lot of fun to use.